[Music]
let's go to james in shreveport
louisiana home of daniel cormier and
dustin poyne what's up james
how you doing doctor john thanks for
taking my call you got it what's up dude
all right so
uh how can i just kind of stop you
that's that's literally my favorite when
somebody's like all right so uh i always
know it's gonna be good next so
all right i won't interrupt you anymore
bring it on
a girlfriend in college and uh which i
thought which was a a serious
relationship um
so we decided to
take the relationship uh to a level of
intimacy and prior to that we both were
aware that we had previous sexual
relationships so she wanted me to uh to
get tested
for sexually transmitted diseases
and so i did being the young man i was
obviously very excited um however um i
shared the you know the results with her
and whatnot and she
she never shared
her information with me
but at that point i was you know foolish
or whatnot i
i didn't really care so we moved on
two years after that i found out
later on that she in fact
had a sexually transmitted disease and
you know at that point i had it as well
and the relationship ended in a ball of
fire needless to say but um so hold on
hiv or
gonorrhea or hiv and syphilis or
chlamydia like what are we talking about
here so we're talking about hsv2 which
which is one of the non-con curable ones
right um
so
yes so she knew about this she got the
test and she went ahead and slept with
you anyway
um well
i found out that she was taking
medication for it prior to
um prior to meeting me so it yeah it had
it done she's known about this for a
while did what was yeah what was her
reasoning why did she
why would
one yeah why would she have you get
tested
it's not strange actually because she
got burned at some point in a
relationship and so it makes sense that
she'd want to
but it doesn't make sense that she would
say that in turn like what happened to
me i'm going to do to somebody else
yeah what was the reason
we didn't really discuss it that much um
but
i wasn't in a disgusting mood so yeah
with there she had a lot of um a lot of
emotional trauma i think she at one
point was diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder so our relationship
was it was tough um riddled with
i think she had a few attempt or she
said she had a few attempted suicide
attempts and she was also um
participating in self-harm behaviors
so it was how long ago was this man
this was about seven years ago okay so
yeah bring me forward here what's your
question
so fast forward to now um because of
that relationship i don't i have trouble
opening up um you know one day i'd like
to share life with somebody but i have a
hard time even opening up to
to
to relationships and just
trusting somebody enough to to get to
know them and to pursue like a future
and then the the second part to that is
once i do find somebody
who i trust and am willing to open up to
how do i even begin to communicate and
say hey you know i've got this
this issue that's going to be going
forward and
you know how do
i just be open and honest because
there's a lot of i think internally i've
thought about this for the last seven
years there's a part of me is upset with
myself because i allowed this to happen
and you know i made the decision to
engage
and i just
i just don't know what to do i mean it's
been seven years i haven't had any
relationships since then okay so here's
here's the thing a couple things here
number one it happened
okay
cool
yeah there's a period at the end of that
sentence
this thing happened how old are you now
27 okay so you're 20.
this happened
the number of things that 20 there's a
reason we don't let 20 year olds buy
beer they don't make great choices
okay
so let's let 20 year old james off the
hook not off the hook you did a thing
and it it's still in in in your life
right
but let's don't beat up 20 year old
james
let's come to 27 year old james and stop
trying to edit the sentence that
happened you've been trying to edit that
sentence for
eight years seven years
why did this happen what happened i
can't believe she did that it's almost a
decade of your life
right is that fair
yeah okay number two you got
fried
somebody absolutely stone wrecked you
and you got to own that it happened
most people will go through their life
without that happening to them or it
will happen to everybody but not at that
scale and you had a bad one okay
it's similar to somebody who loves has a
loved one dies in a car wreck everybody
drives all the time every day right
there's sex going on all over the place
very few people knowingly give somebody
an sti just because
uh they're
cruel right
that happened to you
fair
yep okay so let's own that let's put a
period into that sentence
the only thing
on the planet
that you can influence is what happens
next
and so any insight any
energy
thoughts what ifs
all of that is a complete and utter
waste of your time
because it solves nothing
the only thing you can do is say okay
what comes next
and two important things come next
number one you have to choose to be in
relationship with people
you don't have to have a romantic
relationship there's plenty of people
that don't want romance that's fine you
said you do
the second thing is how do you tell
somebody you just tell somebody
and will it be embarrassing yep
are you the only one
god no you're not the only one millions
right
yeah so
the path forward i see is it's like
you're
you're running the 400 meter dash and
suddenly coach puts you in the 300 meter
hurdles three whatever it is 300 hurdles
you're like there's these things in
front and the the two options you have
is not run or jump over those things
when you're running
right and so you've got more hurdles in
your path than i do
and the choice is are you gonna not run
or are you gonna run and have to jump
over those things when you go
that make sense
yeah another picture listen i'm
intentionally making this more simple
than i know it is in reality
because all the sti stuff and how like
how awful you would feel if you infected
somebody and how you continually go back
and like why did i why did i what you
keep going back to those
i know those are haunting and i know
those get looped in your head and it
makes you anxious and it makes you
fearful and not trust people all that
and dude you earned not trusting people
you got hosed man
if that happened
but what i want to draw you out of this
is the very simple what happens next and
let's just say you end up meeting 10
people
10 incredible women you are attracted to
them you think they're smart and funny
and real all the things right
and 10 out of 10 of the next 10 you meet
you sit down and say hey before this
goes any further i got to let you know
this
all 10 of them walk away and say thanks
but no thanks
that doesn't mean that you aren't worth
being loved
that means they're not in and i'm going
to move on to number 11.
is that fair
yeah yeah that's fair
and if you've got a
i'll say you got to look at it that way
because you don't want to use people as
an roi like i just want to go out with
you so you'll be my girlfriend whatever
but there's this sense of i'm going to
continue to put myself out there because
i'm worth being loved and yes my 20 year
old me did something stupid and i got
burned and here we are
but i deserve being loved
i deserve being loved i deserve being
loved and also let's be honest you did
get an sti from somebody but you also
spent how long were you all together
about two and a half years okay you
spent a long time with somebody who was
struggling with a lot of things
so take the take the sti off the table
you'd still have relationship trust
issues fair
yeah and that i that's kind of like
where i'm at right now like i've i've
come to terms with with the with the sti
but it's just like i don't even
like i don't even
i
i don't know if it's because i like the
idea of having a life partner and i
don't know i view that as like having a
family and why take a sense that's
success you know whatever it is i know
family is a big part of of what i see in
life is value but
like i don't even
sometimes i feel like i don't even want
to trust people because of because of
the fact that i've been burned like it
it's it's not even just
you know female relationships but like
just friends in general like i just
don't know how to
how to even you know i can be friends
with somebody on the superficial level
but
i don't know if my body just protects or
protects itself
like you you walked into a bear den once
and you got your face bitten off
and
the crummy part is
all the food and nourishment in life is
in a bear den
so you gotta go back
right and your body's gonna tell you
don't go in there
we've been there and we got a face
eating off
and that's when you have to
a
learn some
right
make different choices and you got to
risk
you got to risk
choosing loneliness is choosing to die
young choosing loneliness is choosing to
live a life of misery
and if you reach out and you develop
relationships and connections and you
get burned again you have a season of
grieving and you get back on the horse
and you go again it's like getting food
poisoning do you never eat again because
you got rocket diarrhea for a couple of
days no
right yeah at some point you got to go
back and eat again
yeah is that fair
yeah yeah so at some point and by the
way don't feel bad a part of my life is
also having a picture of a family in a
house and kids running around like
you said that in a way that's like you
know part of my thing i kind of like
want to have a family dude that's not
weird
it's fantastic it's awesome
it's the greatest thing in the world
and you're worth the risk
is that fair
yeah yeah
i just
we do it i don't
yeah i don't know i just don't know like
i don't even know here we go i'm gonna
give it to you i'm gonna give it to you
right at what point do i do i you know
it's like
let's say
i don't know go out on date with
somebody and it's like okay um here's
this dessert okay and here's
the reason you don't have like a scarlet
letter on you or you're like walking
around with a cowbell like unclaimed
uncle that's not you man
there's a bunch of conversations
that
uh not always not always there are
people that meet somebody just have sex
that day that happens all the time
doesn't sound like that's you
so there is a gap between hey let's go
out
i'm getting to know you tell me about
yourself
between that first time you go out in
dessert and by the way
um
i have this
there's
you've boxed yourself into a corner of
either never going out or on the first
date being like okay before we get going
i gotta let you know that it burns when
i pee like there's a total different gap
there right
yeah yeah is that fair
yeah yes so
dude you're i could tell right now you'd
be fun to hang out with
i can because you're kind of chill
and you laugh good you'd be fun to hang
out with
and there will come a point when you
gotta have that conversation and your
heart will be beating fast and you'll be
nervous and the chances of you getting
rejected are high
they are that's reality that's the truth
and
you're worth that risk so real quick
real quick
go first
be vulnerable
and be hospitable what do i mean invite
people to your house stop overthinking
this have four or five people over to
play some stupid game you know what i'm
gonna send you all the cards for humans
so i'm gonna send them to you okay
you can invite people over to your house
and y'all can just use them to play like
i got these from some idiot on the radio
let's play
and um
y'all can use those cards as something
to do you can have people over and say
everybody bring a thing whatever that's
being hospitable
i'm gonna go first y'all are welcome at
my house and maybe only two show up
maybe five shows maybe 12 show up i
don't care invite them all over and tell
them i'm not cleaning up by the way i'm
not going to pretend that this isn't how
i live just come over
and i'm gonna i'm gonna be vulnerable
i'm gonna risk i'm gonna invite y'all
into my place
and i'm gonna go first i'm not just
gonna sit here for the next seven years
later and wait for somebody else to call
me and wait for somebody to call me i
don't know i'm just gonna go i'm just
gonna go i'm just gonna go and you may
invite people over and zero show up none
and you grieve it because because it'll
hurt be a bummer and then you go again
because really what is the other
alternative
netflix
like a another
i don't know fancy diet
like it move i mean what's the
alternative other than to
wow that hurts i'm gonna go again and
i'm gonna go again and i'm gonna go
again
and that it's unpopular james thank you
so much for that call it
not speaking to you i've seen everybody
here it's unpopular mental health advice
it's unpopular relationship advice
that life really hurts
hard it's hard it's a mess when you
think you got it something happens and
when you something happens and something
else it's hard
and you ultimately find yourself in
these moments where it's like what are
the other options
sit
or go heal and go again
sit and go heal and go again
and i'm not saying keep running back
into the same bear den don't go back
into that one ever again because you got
your face eaten off
but you gotta go on another one
i'm not saying go eat you know
seven day old pizza from a nasty place
don't do that again
but you gotta eat
you gotta go find a place to eat
people who got really have relationship
trauma whether it's sexual abuse whether
it's um and and by the way what you
experienced is trauma you experienced
abuse somebody abused you they took
advantage of you
and they forever altered your life
because of their lack of character and
their lack of integrity and their desire
to hurt you which is what they did
living in that trauma understanding that
like it happens man and then we're all
faced with this one awful scary
devastating question what do we do now
and as for me and my friends and my
community and the people that i love and
that includes you james
i'm gonna say let's get up and go again
we may have to jog and our walk first
and then jog before we get up to a run
but let's get up and go again let's get
up and go again and
let's get up and go again
you're worth it